hello end oops welcome to this video
playing Grey Warden from Germany and
this is in new opponent yeah micro gone
offline always I almost always get good
positions but hmm John it's not like I
win every game absolutely not positions
are very often quite murky and then I
get into trouble okay so what is the
deal I can go look hbu know then you
will take and play a form can also play
against his King side um kingside ideas
Queen to g3 is sometimes a good idea
against it
yeah this kind of super high rating for
my my never it's tough because you have
to really win all those games like the
2400 you have to beat very very very
very high scores and it's not that easy
to do if I lose against this guy I look
like 30 points so it it's not that easy
to keep such a lofty rating ok ok wants
to go p5 before of course yeah why not
ok
and oh my queen is kind of off side and
okay I can do this age for stuff but is
it doing much he will pretty quick with
b5 hmm I didn't play that one girl
absolutely not but okay it's difficult
now to prevent
okay this this will be very sharp now
okay now i see that after i take hmm
after i take a night x is actually
threatening both 92 and 93 and this is a
huge problem I don't want to play 91 but
maybe i have 2 1 i'd be one yuck okay so
this is one of those one of the cases
where I don't have a good position I
with this opening this looks absolutely
bad absolutely bad i think you should
really just go g5 now quite often this
is a bad idea because you shut down on
the position on the King side and white
is better on the queenside but well yeah
yeah I'm not better on the queenside it
makes an awful lot of sense now play g5
with black not that are threatening
maybe I'll threatening g52 to bust open
the kingside this might be the case
actually I think I'm threatening this
yeah this is a good move it's just a
good move okay so and this to get the
Queen around if i get to somehow
coordinate it he might be just able to
take and play Knight be three something
like that
one thing however is ok I'm ahead on the
clock yet it's not quite clear to me
what this move does it connects rooks ok
ok so if i take this the immediate 93
around the corner wow I can play Knight
f2 what then my green is so far away
from the action
and 93 was couldn't couldn't allow that
you can just take and play 9 p-3 and
this is just an excellent shape
Pinkel 94 oh my goodness
my queen my queen rooks III is coming I
have no square with this bishop here
Wow
my queen who helped oh wow black resign
yeah I guess it's it's still applies and
it's better to be lucky than good I got
completely outplayed in this game so
Queen f3 g3 is a bad idea so this much I
I have learned from from this position
yeah I don't know what to do Quincy to
maybe yeah this this was a bad idea you
just get this super quick play on the on
the queenside Joe they're black it's
just an excellent shape Wow yeah this
was a bad idea tween a 3g three
absolutely not good yeah the engine says
it's equal but this is such a difficult
position to play however what I like is
the engine suggestion here it wants to
go King F to G to this is a very good
idea then I can get to get the Queen
back then I might believe that I'm still
okay but not the way I played have like
a sis just clearly better yeah and I'd
see one was always was very desperate
already I guess he wanted to play rook
c2 if he plays this I'm just lost them
this is a remarkably bad position Wow
yeah okay I should not play the opening
like that it was just awfully played
okay thanks for watching